Я німкеня, і більшість сприймає мене як пунктуальну людину.
Зрештою пунктуальність вважається німецькою чеснотою.
Але, чесно кажучи, це не завжди про мене.
Тому сьогодні я хочу дізнатися, чи справді німці такі пунктуальні,
якими їх вважають.
Зачекай, я теж тут, твоя внутрішня німкеня!
Твоє маленьке німецьке сумління!
І я можу тебе запевнити, що я - завжди пунктуальна.
Ну, якщо ти так кажеш…
Гляньмо, наскільки німці пунктуальні у вільний час,
у громадському житті та на роботі.
Звучить добре! Я доведу тобі, що ми завжди пунктуальні.
Німці та робота - ось що одразу асоціюється
з пунктуальністю та ефективністю.
Зазирнімо в офіс, аби перевірити, чи це правда.
Але це надто впритул.
Чому ж? Мені потрібно лише 15 хвилин, щоб дістатися до роботи.
А моя зустріч о 8-ій.
А якщо трамвай спізниться?
Ти ж запізнишся! Твоя шефиня очікує, що ти будеш вчасно.
Гаразд, можливо, ти маєш рацію, я поспішу.
Тепер я прийшла надто рано.
Ти не можеш з'явитися на зустріч настільки рано.
Адже "П'ять хвилин зарано - пунктуальність німця".
Ти ж знаєш це німецьке прислів'я.
Гм-м… Тоді я піду ще за кавою.
До завтра!
Оце ще необхідно зробити!
Звісно.
Гей, стоп! Зараз 5 вечора, час іти додому!
Але я ще мушу це завершити.
Але вже кінець робочого дня! Геть звідси!
Ти думаєш?
Звичайно! Ми, німці, пунктуальні,
навіть коли йдеться про кінець робочого дня.
Ми найменше у світі працюємо понаднормово,
адже працюємо ефективно та починаємо і закінчуємо пунктуально.
Так, ми працюємо дедалі менше понаднормово.
Але пунктуальні та ефективні ми не завжди!
Я мушу це закінчити, але обіцяю, що піду через 15 хвилин, гаразд?
Домовилися!
Звичайний робочий день.
Можна з упевненістю сказати, що німці цінують пунктуальність на роботі.
А як щодо вільного часу? Ходімо!
Я зустрічаюся зі своєю подругою Лізою.
Ми вчасно!
Звісно, я не хочу змушувати її чекати
Де ж вона?
Вона точно зараз прийде, не переживай.
Перевір телефон, вона щось написала?
Ні, дивно…
Як нечемно! Вона марнує наш час!
Згідно з опитуваннями, більшість німців очікують,
що ви прийдете пунктуально або зі спізненням
максимально на п'ять хвилин.
Вибач за спізнення! Мій телефон розрядився,
інакше я б неодмінно попередила.
Без проблем!
Німці люблять, коли вибачаються за спізнення.
Тоді все швидко забувається.
Я теж. Треба буде незабаром знову на каву зустрітися. Чао, чао!
А як щодо вечірок? Коли приходять пунктуальні німці?
З цим усе трохи складніше.
Тут пунктуальність залежить від контексту вечірки.
І хто взагалі приходить на вечірку пунктуально?
Ми! І ми маємо ще щось принести із собою, тому поспішай.
Ходімо.
Ой, що ти тут робиш?
Хіба вечірка не о 8-ій вечора?
З 8-ої вечора.
Коротке тлумачення: з 20-ої - не означає бути пунктуальним.
Але контекст важливий. Чим менша вечірка,
тим більше очікування, що гості зберуться більш-менш пунктуально.
А якщо вас запросили на вечерю, то приходити слід справді вчасно.
Гаразд, тоді запитай, чи можеш ти їй чимось допомогти.
О, вибач, можу я тобі чимось допомогти?
Так, звісно.
Хух, далеко не все так просто з німецькою пунктуальністю.
Німці дуже пунктуальні на роботі, але в особистому житті все не так строго.
Залишається ще з'ясувати, наскільки пунктуальне
громадське життя в Німеччині. Приміром, транспорт.
Дивно, що потяга досі нема, чи не так?
Зовсім не дивно.
Але ж це не типово для Німеччини!
Відправлення о 16:05.
Сьогодні приблизно на 10 хвилин пізніше.
10 хвилин?! Неймовірно!
Чесно кажучи, таке трапляється постійно, розслабся.
Німецькі потяги доволі ненадійні.
Ми на 19-му місці з 27 країн ЄС!
Здивована?
Ганьба! Адже ми запізнимося на зустріч.
Не хвилюйся, я це врахувала. Ми ще встигаємо.
Потяг запізнюється на 35 хвилин.
А тепер?
Що ж, реальність, схоже, не зовсім відповідає кліше.
Хоча ми любимо пунктуальність!
Абсолютно! Пунктуальність є цінним надбанням у Німеччині.
Це історично закріплено в німецькій культурі.
А наскільки пунктуальні ви?
Пишіть нам у коментарях на YouTube!